Mein Name ist Yusuf Sejkin. Ich bin heute der zuständige Arzt für Sie und werde das erste Gespräch mit Ihnen führen.
Erstmal benötige ich ein paar persönliche Daten von Ihnen und dann sprechen wir über Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden.
Falls Sie Fragen haben, suggen Sie bitte nicht, mich zu unterbrechen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Thomas Zimmermann.
Herr Zimmermann, am Ende Doppel N, oder?
Ja, Herr Doktor.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Zimmermann?
Ich bin 46.
46. Wie? Ihr Geburtstatum bitte.
1. Juli 1979.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 94 Kilogramm.
Ich bin 1 Meter 74.
Haben Sie einen Hausarzt oder eine Hausarztin?
Mein Hausarzt heißt Jürgen Klinsmann.
Jürgen Klinsmann. Was für Sie heute so ein sehres Thema? Welche Beschwerden haben Sie?
Herr Doktor, ehrlich zu sagen, ich habe Bauchschmerzen.
Seit 5 Tagen habe ich Bauchschmerzen.
Im ganzen Bau.
Ich habe immer volle Gefühle.
Blähungen. Das stört mich.
Alle sind seit 5 Tagen, oder?
Ja, ja.
Könnten Sie bitte diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Umstechend oder brennend?
Ja, es gibt ein drückendes Gefühl.
Das ist die Füße. Im ganzen Bau.
Ich kann es nicht korrigieren. Manchmal kommen, manchmal gehen.
Ich kann es nicht korrigieren.
Schmerzen sind nicht dauerhaft.
Ich habe immer Schmerzen, aber manchmal kommt es stärker.
Sind Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10, wobei 10 am stärksten ist?
Nicht schlimm. Es sind vielleicht 5, aber das stört mich nicht.
Momentan 5?
Ja.
Strahlen Sie Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Nein, ich habe nicht gefangen. Mir ist nicht gefangen.
Hatten Sie das schon mal?
Was habe ich schon mal?
Diese Beschwerden.
Ja, ja. Ich hatte diese Beschwerden für 3 Monate, 10 Monate.
Letzter Jahr habe ich manchmal diese Beschwerden.
Für 3 Monate, für 6 Monate?
Für 10 Monate hatte ich auch. Letzter Jahr hatte ich auch.
Haben Sie dagegen irgendwelche Medikamente genommen?
Nein, ich habe einen Kreutertie getrunken.
Das hilft mir früher.
Aber letztes Mal habe ich getrunken, aber es hilft mir nicht.
Kreutertie.
Aber Sie nehmen bisher keine Medikamente?
Nein.
Haben Sie Brustschmerzen?
Ich habe Brustschmerzen.
Aber manchmal fühle ich den Oberbauch.
Manchmal den Unterbauch. Manchmal den Mitbauch.
Ist Ihnen ein saures Aufstoßen aufgefallen?
Ja, weniger, aber ich fühle es.
Gibt es irgendwelche Auslöser dafür? Haben Sie es bemerkt?
Zum Beispiel nach dem Essen oder nach dem bestimmten Essen, bestimmte Lebensmittel?
Mir ist nicht aufgefallen.
Aber mir ist aufgefallen, dass ich manchmal Durchfall habe, manchmal Verstopfung habe.
Im Wechsel. Und manchmal höre ich mein Darmgeräusch.
Seit wann haben Sie Diago und Verstopfung?
Durchfall und Verstopfung?
Wenn ich diese Bauchschmerzen habe, manchmal habe ich Verstopfung.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen?
Dagegen was? Ich verstehe nicht.
Dagegen Verstopfung und Durchfall.
Ich nehme nichts. Ich trinke Tee.
Momentan haben Sie Durchfall oder Verstopfung?
Dann habe ich Durchfall. Ich habe heute dreimal meinen Darm entlärt.
Wie sah Ihr Stuhl aus?
Ja, das ist manchmal wasrig, manchmal stressig.
Haben Sie Blut im Stuhl bemerkt?
Nein.
Ist Ihnen Häschenstolpen aufgefallen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Atemnot?
Nein, nein, Herr Doktor. Ich habe keine Atemnot.
Haben Sie Schwellungen im Bauch oder in anderen Körperregionen?
Wenn ich Blut habe, ist mein Bauch wie ein Gehschwollen.
Aber ich weiss nicht, ob das Gehschwollen ist.
Haben Sie Schluckbechwerden?
Ich muss sehr oft Pupsen.
Ich habe keine Schluckbechwerden.
Haben Sie Fieber, Stellfrost oder Nachschweiß?
Nein, Herr Doktor. Ich habe keine.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Manchmal habe ich Übelkeit.
Möchten Sie sich übergeben?
Nein.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Haben Sie etwas Verdobenes gegessen?
Nein, nein, Herr Doktor.
Aber mir ist aufgefallen, dass wenn ich viel Stress habe,
besonders wenn ich miteinander streite oder bei der Arbeit viel Unterdrück habe,
oder mit dem Chef oder dem Kollegen ...
Was sind Sie? Von der Uhr?
Ich bin Automobilkaufer.
Verkäufer.
Haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit?
Haben Sie Stress in Ihrer Familie oder in Ihrem Freundkreis?
Ja, natürlich. Ich habe drei Kinder. Sie haben immer etwas.
Sie möchten immer etwas.
Ich habe Stress.
Manchmal streite ich mit meiner Frau. Deswegen habe ich Stress, Herr Doktor.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit, Herr Zimmermann?
Mein Appetit ist gut.
Aber vielleicht habe ich wegen dieser Schmerzen drei Kilo abgenommen.
In einem Jahr.
Können Sie gut schlafen?
Ja, mein Schlaf ist auch nicht gut. Ich kann nicht durchschlafen.
Wenn ich ein Glas Secht trinke, schlafe ich besser.
Wie oft trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, drei oder vier Mal pro Tag trinke ich ein Glas Secht.
Drei oder vier Gläser täglich?
Nein, nein. Drei oder vier Mal pro Woche.
Ein Glas.
Secht. Ein Glas.
Wie ist Ihr Wasserlasten, Herr Zimmermann?
Es ist ganz normal.
Waren Sie schon einmal wegen dieser Beschwerden beim Arzt?
Ja, ich war vor zwei Jahren beim Hausarzt.
Er hat mir etwas gegeben, aber ich erinnere mich nicht.
Wurde bei Ihnen eine Festdiagnose gegeben?
Nein, es gab mir ein Seftchen für Verstopfung gegeben.
Wurde bei Ihnen eine Magenspiegelung oder Koloskopi durchgeführt?
Nein.
Oder eine Darmspiegelung?
Secht.
Haben Sie irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich hatte zwei oder drei Mal Handweginfektion und Antibiotika angenommen.
Wie heißt das? Erinnern Sie sich?
Nein, ich weiß nicht, Herr Doktor. Ich erinnere mich nicht.
Wann war die letzte Infektion?
Vor zwei Monaten.
Haben Sie noch andere chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe auch Bluthochdruck.
Seit wann haben Sie das?
Seit zehn Jahren.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen?
Ich nehme nur 10 mg.
Einmal, oder?
Einmal, ja.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert, Herr Simmermann?
Ja, mein Wurmfortsatz entfand vor 15 Jahren.
Hatten Sie noch andere Operationen?
Nein, einmal.
Haben Sie Allergien oder Unfertiglichkeiten?
Ich habe eine Stau-Allergie.
Eine Ausstau-Allergie?
Ja, eine Ausstau-Allergie.
Wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Manchmal schnuppig, manchmal mit Renitis.
Rauchen Sie, Herr Simmermann?
Ja, ich rauche eine Alpschachter-Sigaretten.
Seit wann rauchen Sie?
Seit 20 Jahren.
Seit wann trinken Sie Alkohol?
Seit vielen Jahren.
Trinken Sie außer Sekt eine andere Alkoholart?
Manchmal trinke ich Bier mit meinen Freunden.
Wie oft trinken Sie?
Einmal proben, Herr Oda.
Bitte nehmen Sie die folgenden Fragen nicht persönlich.
Aus medizinischen Gründen fragen wir immer.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Drogen?
Wie zum Beispiel Marihuana, Aschis?
Als ich im Gymnasium war, habe ich eine oder zwei Mal Joint gehabt.
Ein zweimal Joint.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja.
Leben Sie mit Ihrer Frau?
Ja, ich lebe mit meiner Frau.
Sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Sie sind gesund, ja.
Gut zu hören.
Gibt es irgendwelche chronischen Erkrankungen in Ihrer Familie, Herr Zimmermann?
Meine Mutter leidet an Schlaganfall.
Gut zu hören.
Und Bluthochdruck.
Ihr Vater?
Mein Vater ist leider an Lungenkrebs gestorben.
Gut zu hören. Meine sehr beileid.
Herr Zimmermann.
Können Sie es wiederholen an Herzinfarkt, oder?
Nein, Lungenkrebs.
In welchem Alter?
Mit vielleicht 80.
Haben Sie eine Schwester?
Ich habe eine Tochter.
Eine Schwester.
Ist sie gesund?
Sie ist gesund.
Träben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ja, ja. Ich immer Joggen.
Sind Sie vollständig, Herr Zimmermann?
Ja, ich hatte alle empfohrene Impfungen.
Gut.
Waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Vor drei Jahren war ich in China.
Vor drei Jahren.
Gut.
Ich möchte kurz zusammenfassen.
Sie klagen seit fünf Tagen Bauchschmerzen im ganzen Bauch.
Darüber hinaus klagen Sie über Lärmungen, voller Gefühl und die andere Durchfall und Verstopfung, Herr Zimmermann.
Ja, ja.
Haben Sie weitere Beschwerden?
Bauchschmerzen besonders.
Meinerseits habe ich alle wichtigen Fragen gestellt. Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ja Herr Doktor, ich habe viele, viele Mal Arzt und Ärztin besucht. Was kann ich haben? Was denken Sie?
Es ist zuführend etwas Genaues zu sagen, Herr Zimmermann. Jetzt werde ich eine körperliche Untersuchung durchschrüren.
Danach werde ich Blut abnehmen und wildgebende Verfahren veranlassen. Mit den Ergebnissen können wir mehr überspringen, Herr Zimmermann.
Werden Sie mit Schlauch untersuchen?
Wie gesagt, es ist zuführend etwas Genaues zu sagen, Herr Zimmermann. Aber gegebenenfalls können wir es durchschrüren.
Ich habe Angst, ich möchte nicht Schlauch.
Machen Sie sich deswegen keine Sorgen. Wir verabreichen oder wir geben Beruhigungsmittel. Sie erinnern sich nichts.
Ist das schmerzhaft oder?
Es ist ein bisschen schmerzhaft, aber wir geben leichter Narkose und Sie spüren ganz nichts, Herr Zimmermann.
Ja, durch den Aftereich möchte ich nicht. Unbedingt möchte ich nicht durch den Aftereich.
Wenn Sie nicht möchten, dürfen wir nichts machen, Herr Zimmermann. Machen Sie sich deswegen keine Sorgen.
Okay, Herr Doktor, vielen Dank.
Wir können eine Untersuchung durchschrüren, wenn Sie Erlaubnis geben.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Gerne.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt. Ich würde Ihnen gerne einen neuen Patienten vorstellen, den ich eben in der Notaufnahme gesehen habe.
Bitte schön.
Es handelt sich um Thomas Zimmermann, ein 46-jähriger Patient, geboren am 1.07.1979.
Er ist 1,74 Meter groß und 94 Kilogramm schwer.
Er stellte sich bei uns vor aufgrund seit fünf Tagen bestehender, kolikartiger, drückender Bauchschmerzen oder Abdominage im ganzen Bauch, ohne Ausstrahlung.
Als Begleitsymptomen liegen Meteorismus vor.
Er gab es an, diese Beschwerden vor drei Monaten und zehn Monaten zu haben.
Er war deswegen bei Hausarzt gewesen.
Er hat bisher keine feste Diagnose gestellt.
Davor trug er dagegen Freutatee.
Aber dieses Mal hat es ihm nicht geholfen.
Darüber hinaus klagte er über die Abwechslung der Diagnose und Obstepation.
Er hat heute dreimal Diagnose.
Es sah wasrig aus.
Die Frage nach Refluox, Tachycardi, Dystnoe, Oedema wurde verneint.
Er leidet an Stress bei der Arbeit.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist unaufällig bis auf Gewichtabnahme innerhalb von zwölf Monaten.
So wie Insomnie, Form von Durchschlafstörungen.
Er leidet an Vorerkrankungen, leidet an seit zehn Jahren arterieller Hypertonie.
Dagegen nimmt er nur etwas einmal täglich ein.
Er hatte zwei bis drei Mal Harnweginfektion.
Die letzte war vor zwei Monaten.
Es wurde mit Antibiotikum behandelt.
Aber der Name des Medikaments ist nicht erinnerlich.
Vor fünfzehn Jahren wurde eine Appendiktum durchgeführt.
Er hatte eine Allergie gegen Staub, die sich mit Renitis äußerte.
Er ist Raucher, zehn Perkurs.
Er trinkt Alkohol, zwei bis viermal wochenlich Sekt und ein Bier pro Woche.
Er hat ein bis zwei Mal Joint konsumiert, als er im Gymnasium war.
Er ist verheiratet. Er lebt mit seiner Frau zusammen.
Er hat drei gesunden Kinder.
Er ist Automobilkauf.
In der Familienanamnese fand sich Apoplexy und arterieller Hypertonie bei der Mutter.
Der Vater ist mit 60 Jahren an Lungenkrebs verstorben.
Die Schwester ist gesund. Er ist vollständig geimpft.
Die Reiseanamnese ist unauffällig.
Meine Verdachtstheorose lautet auf Reisdarm-Syndrom.
Dafür schiebt es.
Er hat Bauchschmerzen, aber die Schmerzintensität wurde mit fünf bewertet.
Er hatte vor drei und zehn Monaten ähnliche Beschwerden.
Aber bisher keine feste Diagnose.
Er hat Stress bei der Arbeit.
Als Differentialdiagnosen kommen Gastroenteritis, chronische entzündliche Darmerkrankungen
und Cholestitis in Betracht.
Zur Diagnostik würde ich zunächst bei den Patienten eine körperliche Untersuchung durchschauen.
Im Rahmen der Untersuchung würde ich zunächst die Vitalparameter erfassen.
Anschließend würde ich den Patienten inspizieren, palpieren und auskiltieren.
Bei der Inspektion achte ich auf den Allgemeinen Zustand des Patienten und die Hautfarbe des Patienten.
Bei der Palpation achte ich auf Druckschmerzen, Loslassschmerzen, Abverspannung und mögliche Organe und Megali im Bauch.
In diesem Fall ist die Palpation wegweisend für uns.
Zu weiteren Diagnostiken würde ich Labouruntersuchungen durchschauen,
um das Blutbild, die Entzündungswerte, die Leber- und Nierenwerte und A, G, Gt, Amylaswerte, Lipaswerte zu bestimmen.
Zu weiteren Abklärungen würde ich die operative Diagnostik durchschauen.
Zunächst würde ich Röntgenaufnahme des Abtomens veranlassen, um eine mögliche Perforation auszuschließen.
Danach würde ich die Sonographie des Abtomens durchschauen.
Wenn die Befunde unklar sind, können wir Zete veranlassen.
In diesem Fall leidet er seit ungefähr einem Jahr auf Bauchschmerzen.
Deswegen sollten wir die Magenspiegelung der Osephago-Gastrodendonskopie durchschließen,
um eine mögliche Krebs- oder eine andere Magen- oder Osephagos-Pathologie auszuschließen.
Gegebenenfalls können wir auch Koloskopie durchführen.
Sollte sich meine Verdachtstdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich den Patienten zuerst eine Spasmolytik verabreichen,
um die Bauchschmerzen zu behandeln.
Ich würde auch eine psychiatrische Konzilveranlassung, um die Therapie zu optimieren.
Ich empfehle ihm Psychotherapie, Gruppentherapie und gegebenenfalls Antidepressant,
wie zum Beispiel Segatonin, Paroxetin.
Meine Planung ist, wenn sie mir erlaubt geben, würde ich durchschauen.
Mit diesem Vorgehen ist einverstanden. Würde ich mit den geplanten Untersuchungen fortfahren.
Herr Kollege, Sie haben gesagt, dass Ihre Verdachtstdiagnose Reis-Derm-Synrom ist. Wie können Sie das Beständnis bestätigen?
Reis-Derm-Synrom ist eigentlich eine Ausschlussdiagnose, Herr Oberast.
Deswegen müssen wir eine mögliche Organopathologie ausschließen.
Mit geplanten Maßnahmen, wie zum Beispiel Sonographie, Ozefagodionoskopie, Koloskopie.
Würden Sie in diesem Fall ERCP durchführen?
In diesem Fall ist ERCP nicht ein Symbol, Herr Oberast, am Anfang.
Wenn wir einen Gallenstein im Gallenwege oder im Pankreaswege beurteilen, sollten wir auf ERCP durchführen.
Was erwarten Sie bei der Ultraschalldesabdommens?
In diesem Fall erwarte ich eigentlich keine Befunde. Nur wegen Luftansammlung vermähete ich einen Kolonschnitt.
Bei der Röntgen des Abdommens achte ich auf Perfektionsbefunde, freie Luftansammlung.
Und?
Und auch Illus, Megakolon oder Volvulus.
Möchten Sie in diesem Fall Herzensime?
Ja, Herr Oberast, Sie haben recht. Er leidet an drückenden Bauchmessen.
Deswegen sollten wir Herzensime analysieren oder überprüfen.
Wie können Sie einen Rektalkrebs bei der Körperentzündung ausschließen?
Bei der ersten Masnahme würde ich eine digitale Rektale Untersuchung durchschauen.
Bei der digitalen Rektale Untersuchung können die Tumorgewebe tastbar sein.
Was verschreiben Sie bei den Patienten nach der Akutbehandlung?
Nach der Akutbehandlung sollte sich meine Verdachtstheagnose bestätigen.
Ich würde Antidepressant wie Serotonin, Paroxetin oder Wendlerfaxon empfehlen.
Psychotherapie ist sinnvoll. Und wir können einen Buskopan verschreiben.
Wie können Sie den Patienten in Bewegung gehen?
Herr Oberast, ich habe es vergessen. Natürlich sollten wir es empfehlen.
Wir sollten täglich ausreichende körperliche Aktivitäten empfehlen.
Aber sie treten regelmäßig Sport.
Ich habe diese Frage gestellt. Er joggt. Er macht Joggen.
Joggen ist nicht beweglich. Stabilisiert denke ich.
Ich empfehle ihm aktive regelmäßige Aktivitäten.
Können Sie uns die Koloskopie aufklären?
Natürlich, Herr Oberast. Koloskopie ist eine bildgebende operative Diagnostik.
Bei der können wir Rektum, Kolon und bis Terminaliläum beurteilen.
Mit Hilfe eines Schlauers. Das Schlauch enthält eine Kamera und eine Lichtquelle.
Wir führen das Schlauch durch den Afte bis zum Terminaliläum.
Während dieser Untersuchung können wir Darm, Wande und Polyp darstellen.
Auch können wir eine Gewebeprobe entnehmen.
Das ist eine schmerzhafte Untersuchung.
Deswegen sollten wir leichte Narkose verabreichen.
Vor der Untersuchung sollten die Patienten vorbereitet werden.
Vor einem Tag vor der Untersuchung darf er nicht feste Lebensmittel essen.
Vor sechs Stunden darf er nicht trinken.
Nach der Untersuchung braucht er eine begleitende Person.
Er darf nicht Auto fahren oder eine wichtige Entscheidung nicht getroffen.
Wie ernährt man den Patienten in diesem Fall? Was empfehlen Sie?
Das ist ein bisschen kompliziert.
Vor drei Tagen darf er nicht trinken.
Aber Sie haben schon gesagt, dass er trinken darf.
Der Patient sollte Abfüßmittel nehmen.
Ein Vortrag vor der Untersuchung.
Vielen Dank, Herr Kollegen. Bitte gehen Sie in den Infodisk und nehmen Sie Ihre Zertifikate.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich würde ihn gerne vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit dafür?
Ja, bitte.
Ich berichte über den 46-jährigen Patienten, Herrn Thomas Zimmermann.
Der Patient ist 1,74 Meter groß und 94 Kilogramm mit.
Der Patient stellt sich heute bei uns wegen seit fünf Tagen bestehender Koligartiger,
diffuserdrückender Bauchschmerzen vor.
Außerdem klagt er über Diarrhea und Obstipation im Wechsel.
Darüber hinaus sind die Begleitsymptome Nausea, Flatulenz, Metaurythmus, Föllegefühl, Pirosis und Pirosis.
Der Patient hat berichtet über drei Kilogramm Abnahme in einer Säure.
An Vorerkrankungen gab er an, dass er seit zehn Jahren Arteriehypertonie leidet
und drei Mal Handwerkinfektion hatte in den letzten zwei Jahren.
Er nimmt regelmäßig nur 10 Milligramm morgens und trinkt Kreuterthil gegen Bauchbeschwerden oder Abdominalabdomenbeschwerden.
Bei der Patienten wurde vor 15 Jahren Apendektomie durchgeführt.
Er ist vollständig geimpft und leidet unter Stauballergie, die sich mit Renitis äußert.
Er raucht halb Schachtel Zigaretten seit 20 Jahren, ein Glas Segt drei- oder viermal pro Woche seit 20 Jahren und Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Sein Vater ist an Lungenkrebs mit 80 gestorben und seine Mutter leidet an Schlaganfall und Arteriehypertonie.
Er hat eine Schwester und sie ist gesund.
Er trinkt regelmäßig Joggen und ist verheiratet und hat drei gesunde Kinder.
Er ist Automobilverkäuferin und bei der Arbeit ist er unter Stress.
Er leidet unter Insomnie in Form von Durchschlafstörungen.
Ich höre den Bauch ab, ob es erhöhte oder verminderte Darmgeräusche gibt.
Ich achte auf Hautveränderungen ob ichterus oder vergrößerte Jubilären oder Venen gibt.
Ich werde Blut abnehmen, besonders Blutbildentzündungsparameter CRP, BSG, Nieren- und Lebewerte und natürlich Tumormarkat CEA 125 und CEA 19.
Ich werde auch einen Ureas-Atemtest durchführen und eine Stuhlprobe abnehmen, um mögliche Blut im Stuhl zu bestätigen oder auszuschließen.
Ich werde auch eine Bauchsonographie durchführen, um mögliche vergrößerte Hepa- oder Mils- oder Ciptenomegaly- oder Hepatomegaly-Auszuschleisen oder Bauch-Tumors auszuschließen.
Ich werde auch eine Gastro-Ösephagia- und Glocken-Düadenoskopie durchführen, um mögliche Magenkrebs oder Magengezücher oder Ulkusdüaden, Ulkusventriküli auszuschließen.
Ich werde auch eine Bauchsonographie durchführen, um mögliche Magentücher und Blut- und Mils- und Ciptenomegaly-Auszuschleisen zu bestätigen.
Okay, waren der Patient früher beim Arzt wegen NL5?
Der Patient hat vielmals ihre Hausarzt besucht, aber eine bestimmte Diagnose wurde nicht festgestellt.
Hat der Patient einen Maschinen?
Nein, der Patient hat keine Endoskopie oder Kolonoskopie.
Wir haben keine Informationen über Sonographie.
Bei der Körperwundherzigung werde ich auch Sonographie fragen.
Oder die Klinik befinden, wir können fragen. Der Patient hat einige Unterlagen, Dokumente dabei.
Wir müssen auf jeden Fall auch die Patientenakte fragen, ob der Patient hat.
Okay, Ihre Verdacht Diagnose ist Reisdarm-Syndrom. Wie wird das Reisdarm-Syndrom diagnostiziert?
Reisdarm-Syndrom ist eine aus Schleisen Diagnose.
Wir müssen zuerst alle organische Diagnosen aus Schleisen.
Beispiel mit Hilfe eines Oesophobos gastro deodenoscopii muslimis, Ulcus pepticus, Ulcus deodenii,
und mit Hilfe Koloskopii muslimis Colitis ulcerosa und auch Morbus cron aus Schleisen.
Nachdem wir alle organischen Diagnosen aus Schleisen haben, können wir ein Reisdarm-Syndrom diagnostizieren.
Das ist eine psychosomatische Diagnose, deswegen hat es viel mit Stress zu tun.
Okay, gibt es einen Zusammenhang mit Stress oder Ernährung?
Der Patient ist immer unter Stress, besonders bei der Arbeit und mit drei Kindern zu Hause.
Manchmal streitet er mit ihrer Frau.
Dann werden die Beschwerden verschlimmer?
Ja, wenn der Patient Stress hat, werden die Beschwerden sich verschlimmen.
Okay, wie häufig treten die Beschwerden auf?
Ich würde den Patienten ambulant behandeln, meine meine Unang.
Die Beschwerden sind chronisch. Seit fünf Tagen sind sie verschlimmert, aber er hat chronische Beschwerden.
Zuerst würde ich eine Lebensstilveränderung empfehlen.
Ich empfehle eine Gewichtabnahme, die 94 kg ist.
Ich empfehle, das Gewicht abzunehmen und auch scharf und fettiges Essen aufzuhören.
Aber der Patient hat eine Gewichtabnahme geschaffen.
Er hat drei Kilogramm abgenommen, aber das ist nicht genug, meine Meinung nach.
Mindestens 10 Kilogramm abzunehmen.
Mit Hilfe des Sports und natürlich der Diät.
Die Ernährung.
Die Ernährung verändern.
Der Patient muss nicht Alkohol trinken und mit dem Zigaretten aufzuhören.
Ich empfehle auch aufzuhören.
Und mit sauriges Essen oder trinken.
Ich empfehle, zu verzichten.
Welche Therapie würden Sie durchgeführt?
Ich empfehle, die Medikamente aufzuwenden.
Beispielmente Methospazmibuskopan gegen Bauchschmerzen.
Und eine Serotonin-Reabteig-Inhibitör.
Auch ich empfehle den Patienten.
Das kann auch hilfreich sein.
Und eine Verhaltnistherapie kann hilfreich sein.
Und eine Psychiatrische Konsole.
Wenn die Beschwerden da sind und wir keine Lösung gefunden haben,
dann werde ich auch eine Psychiatrische Konsole empfehlen.
Ok, können Sie uns die Koloskopie aufklären?
Koloskopie ist ein Bildgebendesverfahren.
Koloskopie besteht aus einem flexiblen Schlauch, einer Kamera, Licht und Linsen.
Wir führen durch den Schlauch ein bis zur Dua-Dynamik.
Wir können gleichzeitig durch den Schlauch ein bis zur Dua-Dynamik.
Wir führen durch den Terminal.
Das ist ein endoskopisches Verfahren.
Wir führen durch den Schlauch ein bis zur Terminal.
Gleichzeitig können wir Bilder auf einem Monitor darstellen.
Und gleichzeitig können wir eine Gewebeprobe entnehmen.
Oder wenn es Blut gibt, können wir stillen.
Wir nutzen Koloskopie nicht nur um zu diagnostizieren, sondern auch um zu behandeln.
Das ist eine Anesthesie, die wir verbreiten.
Wir können die Koloskopie nicht nur um zu diagnostizieren, sondern auch um zu behandeln.
Für zwei Tage muss der Patient mit einer festen Ernährung aufhören.
Für einen Tag muss der Patient nur mit einer festen Ernährung aufhören.
Und vor acht Stunden muss der Patient mit einer festen Ernährung aufhören.
Nur Wasser kann er trinken.
Nach der Untersuchung muss der Patient mindestens zwei Stunden aufhören.
Der Patient kann nicht allein wichtige Entscheidungen treffen oder Auto fahren.
Ein Tag ist wichtig.
Okay, danke für diese Information.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen und würde Ihnen gerne den Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, habe ich, bitte schön.
Mein Name ist Thomas Zimmerman.
Mein Patient ist 46 Jahre alt, 94 Kilogramm schwer, 1,74 Meter groß.
Der Patient steht seit fünf Tagen in der Bechsteinung ganz abdominal Schmerzen ohne Astrologie vor.
Welchen Faktbegriff können wir hier benutzen für ganz Bauchschmerzen, abdominal Schmerzen?
Also generell gesagt,
die Schmerzen sind drückend und kolikartig.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde auf eine Schmerzskala mit 5% bewertet.
Der Patient hatte früher Anliegen und Beschwerden viele Mal.
Meine Kollegin, also der Patient leidet unter einem Abdominal Schmerzen.
Also hat der eine Notfallsituation? Denken Sie so?
Ich habe dem Patienten gesagt, der Patient hatte früher viele Anliegen und Beschwerden.
Die Schmerzintensität war nicht stark, es war 5%.
Ich meine, momentan hat der Patient eine Notfallsituation?
Momentan denke ich, der Patient hat keine Notfallsituation.
Welche Notfallsituationen kennen Sie bei einem Abdominal Schmerzen?
Ja, es gibt viele Notfallsituationen mit Abdominal Krankheit wie Apendektomy, Divertikulitis, Apandistitis, Entschuldigung.
Apandistitis, Divertikulitis, Gastrointestinal Blutung, Ileus und Ovarian Torsion und Perforation.
An welcher Seite erwarten Sie eine Schmerzen bei Apendistitis und Divertikulitis?
Wenn der Patient Apandistitis hat, hat der Patient rechte Unterabdominal Schmerzen.
Wenn der Patient Divertikulitis hat, hat der Patient unterlinke Seite Abdominal Schmerzen.
Und welche Begleitsymptome erwarten Sie bei dieser Erkrankung?
Wenn der Patient Apandistitis hat, gibt es Fieber, Pirexie, Noisea und lossless Schmerzen, Druckschmerzen und Abwehrschwernung.
Und Apathitlosigkeit ist sehr wichtig.
Aber wenn der Patient Divertikulitis hat, hat der Patient wechselnde Obst, Patient und Diary.
Und außerdem der Patient hat Fieber auch und Noisea, Übelkeit, Apathitlosigkeit.
Und ich würde den Patienten Blut abnehmen.
Und wenn der Patient Apandistitis hat, hat er die Schmerzen bei Divertikulitis.
Okay, lass uns ein bisschen über diesen Patienten sprechen.
Also der Patient leidet unter Abdominal Schmerzen. Welche Begleitsymptomen hat er?
Der Patient hat Pirosis, Flatulenz, Meteorismus, voller Gefühl und Noisea.
Und außerdem der Patient hat mir gesagt, die Beschwerden sind mit Stress schlimmer geworden.
Und der Patient hat also Stress.
Und es sind sehr wichtige Symptome, dass der Patient hat...
Welche Stressfaktoren hat der Patient?
Bei der Arbeit und im Alltag.
Was ist er von Beruf?
Der Patient hat Automobilkauf.
Er hat mir gesagt, ich habe viel Stress bei der Arbeit.
Und ich denke, sehr wichtige Symptome sind Wechsel der Obst, Patient und Diary.
Das spricht für, ich denke, Reisdämm-Syndrome.
Also was ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose bei diesen Patienten?
Ja, ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf Reisdämm-Syndrome aus.
Der Patient hat typische Symptome dafür ausgestattet.
Der Patient leidet unter Wechsel der Obst, Patient und Diary.
Und der Patient hat sehr lange vor Geischicht für Anniere Beschwerden.
Und der Patient hat Meteorismus.
Und mit Stress sind die Beschwerden schlimmer geworden.
Das spricht für Reisdämm-Syndrome, denke ich.
An welchen Erkrankungen leidet der Patient?
Der Patient hat Arteriella Hypertonik seit 10 Jahren.
Und vor zwei Monaten hatte er Harnweginfektionen, zwei bis dreimal.
Der Patient wurde mit Antibiotik behandelt.
Aber die Dosis und die Häufigkeit sollte geklärt werden.
Und es wurde bei den Patienten eine Appendekstomie vor fünf Jahren durchgeführt.
Seit wann leidet dieser Patient unter diesen Symptomen?
Ungefähr ein Jahr hat der Patient Anniere Beschwerden.
Er war deshalb bei seinem Hausarzt.
Aber es wurde bei ihm keine bestimmte Diagnose festgestellt.
Welche Fragen sind sehr wichtig bei diesem Patienten?
Ernährung und Stress sind sehr wichtig.
Ich musste den Patienten fragen, ob es eine Ändoskopie oder eine Koloskopie gibt.
Richtig, sehr wichtig.
Und wurde bei dem Patienten eine Koloskopie durchgeführt?
Nein, der Patient hat mir gesagt, es würde bei ihm keine Koloskopie geben.
Okay, dürfen wir eine Koloskopie bei diesem Patienten durchführen?
Ja, natürlich jedenfalls.
Dürfen wir?
Ja, aber nach der Akutbehandlung.
Also was denkt der Patient an eine Koloskopie?
Was hat der Patient über Koloskopie gesagt?
Erinnern Sie sich?
Ja, ich habe nicht erinnert.
Okay, also der Patient macht auf keinen Fall eine Koloskopie.
Er hat eine Koloskopie gesagt.
Und dann hat er gesagt, ich habe eine Koloskopie.
Okay, also der Patient macht auf keinen Fall eine Koloskopie.
Also er hat gesagt, wenn ich alles richtig verstanden habe,
dürfen wir eine Koloskopie bei diesem Patienten durchführen?
Ohne Erlaubnis, ich meine.
Ja, natürlich nicht.
Wir müssen Patienten erlauben, um diese Koloskopie durchzuführen.
Okay, was würden Sie diesem Patienten über Koloskopie empfehlen?
Ja, für Patienten.
Wir werden bei ihnen eine Koloskopie durchführen.
Das ist eine Eingriffenmethode, eine endoskopische Untersuchung.
Das ist eine etwas ungenöme Untersuchung.
Deswegen geben wir ihnen eine Berührungsschmerzmitte,
damit sie bei der Untersuchung schlafen kann.
Vor der Untersuchung sollten sie mindestens sechs Stunden nicht essen und trinken.
Vor der Untersuchung, vor zwölf Stunden am Abend,
müssen sie eine Abfüllmitte mit drei Liter Wasser trinken.
Und morgen wieder drei Liter Wasser mit Abfüllmitte trinken,
damit ihre Diktarme leer ist.
Diese Untersuchung ist ungefährlich und es gibt keine Kontrastmitte und Schutrallen.
Bei der Untersuchung gibt es mögliche Komplikationen wie Blutungen oder andere.
Nach der Untersuchung sollten sie eine wichtige Entscheidung nicht treffen,
wie selbst Auto fahren oder einen Vertrag schreiben.
Wir empfehlen ihnen eine Begleitperson mitzuteilen,
damit sie ihn nach der Untersuchung nach Hause bringt.
Das ist die Aufklärung. Danke für diese Aufklärung.
Können Sie bitte dem Patienten erklären, warum diese Untersuchung sehr wichtig ist?
Diese Untersuchung ist sehr wichtig.
Um die Diagnose zu sichern, müssen wir diese Untersuchung durchführen.
Warum? Wie alle organischen anderen Bauchprobleme auszuschließen.
Vielen Dank, Herr Kollege. Die Zeit ist um.
Bitte gehen Sie zu dem Info-Desk und nehmen Sie Ihre Zertifikat.
Vielen Dank.